[Music]
it was meant to be safe as houses now
the iPhone has been hacked we don't know
who did it
what they took or who was infected but
for two years this attack had the
potential to take well everything to
breach the previously impregnable iPhone
the hackers targeted the Safari browser
they booby-trapped a small collection of
websites which then implanted malicious
code on the iPhone of anyone who visited
it gave hackers access to everything
including Gmail whatsapp and Instagram
and potentially passwords so hackers
could still access accounts after
they've been blocked from the device the
exploit was discovered earlier this year
by researchers at Google they alerted
Apple who fixed the floor security
experts say we shouldn't be too worried
so two threat researchers like myself
and my team it's very concerning because
the user didn't have to do anything but
to end users you know as long as you're
practicing reasonably good
cyber hygiene you're not going to kind
of the doji websites and things like
that then of course you should be
relatively safe Apple declined to
comment at hunks like these are bad news
for a world famous brand but the real
issue it's but anyone who uses their
phone to live their life in other words
all of us because these things are
sucking up so much data any security
lapse leaves us acutely vulnerable that
goes double
now hackers are no longer just teenagers
in bedrooms the way the story's been
described kind of hints that it's not
just individuals being targeted by
criminals but that communities are being
targeted and that slightly suggests
maybe it's actually national governments
that are behind some of this packing
which shouldn't really surprise us
I think our own governments now legally
have access to our own information
through our devices for purposes of
Prevert
in crime this news is another reminder
there's no foolproof way to stay safe
online today apples in the firing line
tomorrow you can guarantee it'll be
someone else roll a mantle Sky News